majority of abortions come from people
who already have children
is that true that is true 60 of
abortions
um happen to women who already have one
child a lot of them are single moms they
don't feel comfortable
supporting multiple children by
themselves yes there's a lot of
pressures on single moms you know first
of all
we do talk a lot about adoption foster
care helping um single moms
help the crisis of fatherlessness but if
you're using that as a justification to
say okay well
they should then kill their second child
let's work to solve her problems
not kill off that second child because
if you're a single mom and you have an
abortion
and you have your already two-year-old
son or your you know your young child
you're in the same exact place you were
before it's not like someone came in and
gave you better job opportunities
better help with your child you just now
have a dead child as part of your family
so the abortion actually doesn't solve
any problem for the single mom
it just makes her the mother of another
child who's dead now
and she still is in the exact same
circumstances she was in before